let's talk about call of duty mobile i
already know what you're thinking
what cod mobile are you okay truth is
this is not okay
if you're getting a little tired of this
i think you should try out call of duty
mobile
why mobile basically since 2019 this
pocket-sized little brother to cod has
formed a massive community and has
featured as much content
as the latest premium titles and even
then i don't think it gets the love it
deserves
so here are seven reasons why i think
you should try out call of duty mobile
if you like call of duty and other fps
games like halo and battlefield
like and subscribe to see more videos
like this alright let's go
call of duty mobile is in its own
universe
they don't need a dramatic story or even
a real reason to add whatever character
they want
we've seen operators from every
storyline including the black ops and
modern warfare series
as well as ghosts and infinite warfare
but it gets
way deeper than that like seriously
brooks
terence brooks the side character from
black ops 1 who was only featured in two
missions brooks
yup he's here and if these more familiar
characters aren't your cup of tea cod
mobile also has its own original
characters mixed in
all of them are 100 badass looking and
the fact that they're only available in
cod mobile
is special this was one of the
inspirations that made me want to make
this video
when ads for cod mobile started hitting
my radar i was delightfully confused
the marketing and general style of cod
mobile is just so damn fun
this is call of duty this sure doesn't
look like it
but i think that's what appealed to me
developers at tme and tencent do such a
fun
and unique job of rolling out the latest
season blueprint or
operator with these flashy ads now don't
get me wrong call of duty ads are all
flashy
but these aren't the serious and dark
ads we're all used to
they're vibrant and thematic one season
it's all about cowboys
and then the next season is an
underwater theme
[Music]
you can't help but smile as you watch
this stuff and yeah warzone is sort of
going this way with its clown bundles
and nail guns but
it feels more at home with mobile
at launch zombies mode was playable on
call of duty mobile
but sadly in march of 2020 zombies mode
was pulled from the game
in a community update cod mobile
announced that they removed the mode to
work on it because it didn't meet their
standard of quality
a little more than a year later and they
announced the mode's return
in a big way teasing characters from the
classic zombies crew
and an all-new siege mode it's a limited
time mode but the developers are open to
the idea of keeping it around
if fans enjoy it in general they've got
their ears open to the community and
their transparency is always so welcome
not to mention we see more and more of a
presence on their official blog posts
first person shooter games on mobile
don't always get the best rap when it
comes to controls
call of duty mobile has plenty of
workarounds that give players
options to tackle this issue and that's
putting it lightly
there are just as many settings if not
more than its console counterpart
and if you're still not keen on touch
controls you don't have to be
there's full support for wireless
bluetooth controllers like the dualshock
4 or the xbox
one wireless controller you don't have
to be the guy that brings this whole
setup into
a bar or anything but if you're
traveling around this is a truly
portable setup that works just about
anywhere
this has got to be the most giving call
of duty ever
you get bonuses for doing just about
anything
checking your mail playing multiplayer
completing challenges
logging in the list goes on in a very
mobile way there's always something
flashing red to catch your attention
but it's always a gift or a way to get
you a gift
i can't keep up with the amount of
goodies this game throws at me
and most of the time it's good stuff
like a weapon skin or credits to
download a weapon skin
you're not always gifted with lousy
stickers like the console titles
there's even a credit shop where you can
pick what you want
did i mention that this entire game is
free
skill based matchmaking has become a
real point of contention with cold war
and
war
zone on both console and pc in short
raven and treyarch have chosen to use
skill-based matchmaking to attempt to
get players and lobbies with people of
the same level of skill
only problem over the last few years
it's been very strict if you do well in
one game
you're pushed into lobbies with higher
skilled players that don't necessarily
reflect your skills
it's almost as if you're punished for
doing well this wasn't always the case
in call of duty games and cod mobile is
a prime example
the match matchmaking here feels like
how it used to in the older days of cod
balanced and a little more fair there's
also ranked play
lastly lobbies don't break up after
every match something i missed more than
i remember
there are 38 maps in cod mobile and just
about
all of them are fan favorites like
modern warfare 3's dome
and black ops 1's summit okay to be fair
lately call of duty games on console
have done a fine job of bringing back
classic maps
in fact some might say they do too much
of this and would favor
new original maps but if you're a fan of
the classics they're all here
i never got a chance to play call of
duty online which was only available in
china and recently got shut down
but this has to be the closest
equivalent to that
not only for the map selection but the
weapons too
like all other aspects of cod mobile the
guns and equipment come from
all walks of call of duty a lot of them
go by different names now but they're
all here
even one-offs like the hg40 from black
ops 3.
remember this thing okay maybe not
everything's perfect
this is something i noticed when i
played a lot of battle royale
potential bots i wouldn't say i'm the
best warzone
player i get a few kills and usually
don't win but when i captured my first
game of battle royale on mobile
i got 12 kills and i won something that
doesn't happen to me very much
i mean even looking back at my gameplay
here you can see that i tend to shoot in
the stomach and chest area
and normally that gets me killed because
i should be aiming for the head
but here i was ripping through everyone
and i couldn't find enough people to
kill fast enough
it was strange bots i don't know
so it could be a combination of the bots
or the skill based matchmaking because
i didn't play that many battle royale
matches before this one you're seeing
here
so who knows they could have put me in a
lower skilled lobby or i could have just
had a good game
here's the deal the answer is yes but
the answer is no not in that way
but the answer is yes so ask me about so
the answer is yes but the answer is also
no so
which the answer you're looking for is
yes but also no
thank you actually games radar put out
an article stating that if you're in a
ranked match you'll be playing with real
people
but that general multiplayer matches can
have bots sprinkled in
they said the same thing about battle
royale 2 but i almost wish i didn't hear
that
so if you don't like bots proceed with
caution or
stick to ranked matches
when i came up with the idea for this
video it revolved around the question
who plays call of duty mobile so i'm
genuinely curious
do you play call of duty mobile do you
want to now
let me know in the comments and if you
want to see more videos about it
drop a like there's so much more to talk
about when it comes to this game
i didn't even bring up the battle pass
the cool comics you can unlock
or even the full desktop support so if
you're curious like i was
i think you should give call of duty
mobile a shot and if you try it come
back here and let me know what you think
until then thanks for watching
[Music]
you